[Music]
our musical guest has had to perform
already due to a scheduling thing so he
performed his part already it's on tape
but we need though is the first part
where we're all sitting here and we're
like hey man this is gonna be great
Sturgill Simpson's here and then we all
go Sturgill Simpson you guys are like
yeah it's Sturgill Simpson we're all
like we can't believe it's really
happening I'm not you're doing it you're
gonna do it keep quiet Andy yeah just
play along come on man TVs a lie you
knew that coming in when it's over we're
gonna shoot the part where we're like
that was really good good night
everybody
and people at home are gonna think if it
was so good why didn't Conan have the
decency to walk over it
and then I just look like it dick will
we do the thing that thing can we just
all scream go over there no God gonna
happen my next guest is here with a song
from his critically acclaimed new album
innately Tim you'll see him he's right
there please
I don't know what he played you play
like a real slow sad you whine he'll
show that's free my final defense is
that it's free that's right
you take your underwear and go home
happy oh I'm sorry
where'd it go Tim we don't give out free
[ __ ] look that's the guy right there
I've always say right there Jeff Rob
[Applause]
I'm always saying to him every day I say
to him Jeff we should give away stuff
he's like then there's less money for us
[Applause]
right
he's wearing three pairs of underwear
right now and Jeff Ross is an [ __ ]
and the show
[Applause]
you
you